Yeah,
well if I were,
I give you that answer of course,
but it was Charles Darwin.
I'll give you another answer and in fact
if I was Adam Smith,
I'd give you a third.
Will have too many answers for you.
I'm the mechanical era sort of obviated
the need for doomsday predictions with
regards to out of control populations
because every time it appeared that we
couldn't do anything more,
we could do something more.
So we had the first green revolutions,
which I just talked about.
The second green revolution came when it
became obvious that if you don't start
fertilizing the ground with her
fertilizers,
with food and supplements,
I should say,
and if we don't start trying to get rid
of the competitor species,
namely the weeds with herbicides and,
and also the pests that want to eat this
crop,
that we can now grow to two profusion as
the result of the invention of dynamite.
By the way.
Uh,
yeah,
because it allowed us to clear the
fields of all those rotten little trees
that we had to get rid of.
So too bad because we could use those
trees again.
Um,
we now find ourselves in another dilemma
where we think the population will peak
and the food supply will dwindle.
So once again,
involved in a Malthusian a mind game.
I don't believe that for a minute.
I think that whatever problem is
presented to the human species,
we've got such a big cerebral cortex.
We can solve it if we all agree to and
that's,
that's the issue.
Do we want to solve the next problem to
usher in the third green revolution?
The second one was all of those
pesticides,
herbicides and fertilizer things,
plus not genetically modified foods,
but certainly a highly selected foods.
And in fact,
if you look at our food since day,
virtually every crop that's grown
originated from some wild plant that you
would not recognize.
An apple is about the size of a pea.
It started out in the middle of Russia
someplace,
and if you took a bite of it,
you wouldn't be able to eat for a week.
Your mouth will be closed.
It's so sour that you wouldn't believe
that someone would actually want to eat
this thing,
but yet domestication of that plant has
now resulted in,
believe it or not,
20,000 different varieties of apples
from a single unit plant.
All right,
so you look at wheat,
it's been the same.
You look at rice,
We've been marvelous at selecting crops
to fit into climates that are suited for
the optimum growth of those plants,
but what was there before?
That's the point there.
There was a natural ecosystem there
before we planted those.